ce matin c'était la foule des grands
jours au pied des pistes
une combinaison de couleurs sur la neige
signe que les vacanciers de la zone b
sont arrivés de quoi donner le sourire
aux professionnels c'est pas forcément
la semaine la plus la plus chargée
on voit qu'il ya un peu de monde dans le
magasin à l'habitude c'est plus mais si
on a quand même bien du monde
ouais mais la saison elle a commencé
quand même un rongeur ne plus travailler
à noël quand même bien grâce à la neige
de culture et après ben les week-ends
ont été très bons en janvier très bien
donc on a fait plutôt plus que l'année
dernière
originaire d'orléans tu cette famille
passe ses vacances d'hiver à métabief
depuis trois ans on est là pour la
semaine
on est arrivé hier avec la neige c'était
c'était magnifique
c'est une station familiale est ce
agréable pour les petits c'est beau
c'est ce qu'il faut pour eux 37 km de
pistes avec vue imprenable sur les alpes
un cadeau venu du froid pour ces novices
ou spécialistes on a une belle des
champs ont fait des descentes on profite
bien c'est un petit peu plus pas de chez
nous donc ça va quoi on est vite arrivée
puis bon là commis à la neige qui est là
donc c'est impeccable
la neige et le soleil toute la semaine
grâce à la neige de culture
le manteau blanc a atteint 80 cm au plus
bas de la station
de quoi voir venir et garantir de bonnes
conditions de glisse sur la période des
vacances au total en attend 150 mille
skieurs à peu près là c'est une période
ont démarré il ya qu une zone
donc on devrait être autour de 20
20 30 milles sur la semaine là la
semaine prochaine sera la plus chargée
pour les activités comme pour les
locations
on a des très beaux taux de remplissage
en tout cas sur la station de métabief
pour les trois prochaines semaines va
cette semaine et les deux suivantes la
dernière il ya plus qu'une zone on a
encore un tout petit peu de place quand
on est plutôt voilà sur des très beaux
taux de remplissage pour tous pour toute
la durée des vacances
la station réalise 80% de son chiffre
d'affaires en hiver dont la moitié
pendant les vacances scolaires un pic à
ne pas rater